uno a uno los monarcas más antiguos de
egipto rodearon la plaza tahrir en una
extravagante muestra del rico patrimonio
del país 22 momias reales fueron
transportadas desde el museo egipcio
donde habían recibido durante más de un
siglo a su nueva residencia de descanso
en el museo nacional de la civilización
egipcia hemos elegido el museo de la
civilización porque queremos por primera
vez exponer las momias de forma
civilizada de forma educada y no para
divertirse como se hacía en el museo
egipcio el convoy del desfile dorado
constaba de 18 faraones y 4 reinas la
mayoría pertenecían al antiguo reino
nuevo que gobernó egipto entre el año
1500 39 antes de cristo y el año 1000 75
antes de cristo- con una banda militar
bailarines y guardias a caballo el
desfile se caracterizó por la pompa y la
fastuosidad a los que estas figuras
estuvieron alguna vez acostumbradas y
viajaron con estilo en vehículos hechos
a medida cada uno de ellos fue
transportado en un contenedor especial
de temperatura controlada para
garantizar que los antiguos miembros de
la realeza pudieran soportar el viaje de
una hora hasta su nuevo hogar se queden
recta o segundo el valiente que reinó en
el sur de egipto en el año 1600 antes de
cristo- encabezaba la flota la procesión
también incluye a ramsés segundo uno de
los faraones más famosos del país
la reina hachepsut también se desplazó
en su época superó las barreras de
género para convertirse en una de las
pocas faraones de egipto las autoridades
esperan que el espectacular desfile y
retransmitido en directo in sufre un
nuevo impulso a la industria turística
un sector que se ha visto paralizado por
la pandemia